[Music]
hello friends just a quick preface there
is a delicious section of the interview
that we moved to the very end of the
episode about how marco taught me and my
girlfriend how to make the perfect
gnocchi so if you want to learn the
secrets behind making delicious
world-class and very simple gnocchi be
sure to listen to the whole thing
hello boys and girls oh my god what am i
12. my voice is cracking people this is
tim ferriss welcome to another episode
of the tim ferriss show that is how
excited i am today to bring to you
uh my guest for this conversation chef
marco kenora let me get into this after
years working with and training under
danny meyer and tom calico you may know
those names at gramercy tavern and craft
chef marco kenora old friend of mine
on instagram you can find him at marco
kenora opened hearth it's h-e-a-r-t-h
in the east village in 2003 before the
neighborhood was a culinary destination
in 2014 marco helped kick off america's
embrace of bone broth with brodo
b-r-o-d-o serving bone broth and coffee
cups out of a side window at hearth over
the years broto has been recognized
consistently as a bone broth pioneer in
outlets such as the new york times time
and good morning america you can visit
brodo.com to try some of their famous
bone broth for yourself i've had many
gallons of it of every possible variety
or visit one of their several locations
in new york city marco's first cookbook
salt taste subtitle the key to confident
delicious cooking was nominated for a
james beard award that's like the oscars
of the cooking and culinary world he is
also the author of a good food day and
brodo subtitle a bone broth cookbook
marco has been profiled in the new york
times serious eats and food and wine he
was a finalist on the next iron chef a
judge on chopped and top chef and he has
appeared on today the chew good morning
america martha stewart and nightline in
may 2017 marco won the james beard award
for best chef in new york city he lives
cooks and gardens with his wife and two
children in yonkers new york you can
find him as i mentioned it on instagram
marco kenora online
restauranthearth.comandbrodo.com
i will warn people in advance i know
that this is family programming uh we
will likely have a font of obscenities
from both of us in this conversation so
just strap in and be prepared for that
marco welcome to the show my friend
tim it's it's so great to be here i am
uh i am absolutely thrilled to be a part
of this amazing cast that you've done
and um you know a little nervous but
more excited than nervous
well you sexy son of a [ __ ] let's just
get right into it
i had an opportunity to go and look back
at some of our early interactions
as documented in the four-hour chef
because we had a lot of adventures and
misadventures
related to all things in that book
and one of the first
conversations i should say the beginning
of one of the very first conversations
we had went like this
it's really assy right grassy i asked no
assy marco repeated loudly over the
bustle of the bar
so could you provide some context for
what we were talking about and if you
can't remember i can certainly well i
refresh the memory i can't remember the
producer of the bottle of wine that we
were referring to
but um
at hearth restaurant there's uh what we
call the kitchen pass so you could like
sit right on our kitchen
and watch everything going on and it's
very loud and the restaurant was full so
there was a lot of noise and i poured
you a sip of a red wine i don't remember
the grape variety maybe you do but it
was a cat a cabernet franc oh okay a cab
franc and uh and we were you know we
were just talking about the wine and i
was smelling it and tasting it as were
you
and um you know it's one of my favorite
wine descriptors because
you know there's this
there's this barnyard horse's ass kind
of thing
in some wines that i
that i really love so
yeah i used assy
and uh your eyebrows went up and i don't
know if you've ever heard that as a wine
descriptor before
i had not and so the the
the the the sentence that i put in the
book was this excited me for three
reasons now you're going to have to
correct my french i'm not going to get
this right but the shin on
which is a bernard baudry 2010 lar
valley was the best cabernet franc i'd
ever had i'd found a wine descriptor i
could understand and i'm very fond of
ass in general now my writing style may
have changed a little bit since
but uh but suffice to say
in this conversation i just want to say
this up front for folks we're not going
to be talking just about cooking we're
going to be talking about living we're
going to be talking about
senses we're going to be talking about
eating
and for most of you out there
regardless of how trendy
fasting is and i'm a big fan of fasting
you can't do it forever
and you likely eat at least a few times
a day or a few times a week so we're
going to be covering a lot of texture
around
sort of the art
of living and nourishment and that can
take a lot of form so i just want to say
that because
part of the reason i enjoy spending so
much time with you is that i feel like a
lot of the
the philosophies and principles
that
that you have formed to kind of guide
your life
overlap a lot with uh some of mine and
that's in part because i've adopted
quite a few of yours so i'm gonna i'm
gonna jump to a section right after this
introduction
to hearth and the four-hour chef in the
professional section there's there's the
domestic the wild the scientists and
then the professional
and
this section is called the mantra the
mantra and here it goes quote cooking is
not hard cooking is not hard end quote
marco repeated this five times during
our evening together quote i feel like
i've pulled the wool over everyone's
eyes as a
successful chef in new york city anyone
could do this end quote come on i said
as i pointed to my vegetable salad which
was ethereal and juicy not an adjective
i used for salads and parenthetical
easily one of the best salads in my life
he laughed and waved a hand dismissively
people say oh my god this is amazing
just dress it while the vegetables are
warm it all soaks in pour the oil on
after the red wine vinegar and add salt
and pepper anyone could do this
oil after the vinegar why marco
explained if you put on the oil first it
deflects the vinegar into the bottom of
the dish where it pools
right so
so this is uh
as best as i could recall it i'm sure i
passed this by you
an example of
simplicity but like powerful simplicity
yeah and we're gonna get to more kind of
crazy stories and hilarious stories
because i have to bring uh our friend
jay-z
not the not the media and hip-hop icon
but uh jeffrey zarofsky easily mix up he
who goes by the initials so he'll have
to make an appearance at at some point
since uh he was he introduced us he
introduced us and he was very much a
brother in arms for the
potential suicide mission that was the
four-hour chef yeah
you never went to culinary school is
that right that is correct
okay now i've heard you
i've read rather you say in interviews
like yeah i'm not that impressed by
culinary school grads i'd rather take
someone who's done a year of staging or
something along those lines yeah could
you
could you elaborate
on that you know cooking is such a trade
and like to think that you can get good
at butchering a salmon by taking a
semester of fish butchery courses is
just kind of absurd i mean as you know
there are of course there's like basic
techniques that you could learn
but but it's like it's like playing a
musical instrument like being adept in a
kitchen and being
efficient with a knife and and being
able to fillet or butcher
meat or fish or or cut vegetables um
you know it's an act of engaging with
your senses so
in my opinion it's just one of those
things that can't be taught
and and it's through repetition you get
great and you know my first job at dinan
de luca in new york city in the early
90s you know it's like i i made soup for
them
at their big shop on broadway and prince
and they would go through 50 gallons of
soup a day
and like i had to cut all the vegetables
for that soup and like you know how i
got my knife skills
from from cutting those vegetables every
day for a couple years i mean it's
incredible so i don't want to put down
places like the culinary institute of
america i mean they do great work
and and i think the kids that come out
of there are are
prepared and they have a good foundation
but ultimately
i just think it's a better proposition
to
get paid for school
and that's what going to work young is
you know it's like you work really hard
and
you might not make a ton of money but
you're getting paid for the knowledge
that you're acquiring and that just
seems like a better roi to me than going
in debt
for a hundred grand
and coming out and then starting that
process
what does it mean to stage people may
not recognize that term
i'm not sure you could even do that
anymore in the current world i mean
certainly not in in new york and i
probably this country at large i mean
maybe in in europe it still goes on but
it's this idea of like okay i don't have
a lot of experience
you're a great restaurant i'm super into
cooking and i want to devote my life to
it so i want to stash at your restaurant
i'm going to go there
and i'm going to kind of watch at first
and then little by little maybe i'll
help
you know with menial tasks and then
maybe that will grow but it's basically
like allow me to be present in your
kitchen so i could learn
and maybe you'll allow me to help too
for free
so it's it's it's apprenticing of a sort
right the s-t-a-g-e i'm imagining that's
french
uh
so that is that's basically a sort of a
lost
practice at this point would you say
yeah totally
how did you first get into
cooking like when did you know
this is what i want to do it was from
growing up in a household with a mom who
cared about cooking and was you know was
a great cook
and we had a garden in upstate new york
one of my earliest memories is my mom
picking zucchini flowers out of the
garden
and then dipping them in a simple
pastella which is just a flour and water
batter and pan frying them in olive oil
and then you know putting a little bit
of salt on them and eating them while
they're hot so it was like from the from
the earth
to the pan to the plate to my mouth in a
matter of an hour and a half
and like that [ __ ] resonated with me and
and it stuck it it's like it's still
with me today so
the the very quick and simple answer is
is from growing up in a home
with a mom who who cared and knew how to
cook and and and
believed in the power of cooking
so for those you've worked with right
what would they say your
superpowers are what are you good at
i'm good at
being demanding without being an [ __ ]
about it you know like i've worked
everybody wants to respect
a chef or a leader who's demanding
and hold you accountable and i think
the tricky part for anybody trying to
drive a kitchen or drive any project
is to like
is to be disciplined and to be demanding
but to be able to do it in a way that
garners
support right instead of the opposite of
support which is like i've worked for
some really demanding guys and i
respected the fact that they wanted it
to be great but they were total [ __ ]
about it and it didn't motivate me to
want to be part of their success
right and i think a nugget of what has
helped me through my career is
i've been able to find that balance of
being a total obsessive perfectionist
demanding
kind of
you know hard knocks guy
but at the same time balance that out
with
making sure they understand it's from a
good place
and from a kind place for the common
good of like being really proud of the
hard work that we're doing
how do you do that so let's if if if we
uh
you don't have to name names but yeah
like how how might the language
look
right you know i mean
and it's like every day you're going to
have a chance to
correct yeah that's what i wanted to say
you know tim it's not so much about
language it's about actions right and
that's the beauty of work and that's the
beauty of kitchens in my opinion is
that happens through
being alongside
and showing everybody that
there's not really a hierarchy and that
you're willing to do whatever it takes
right and you're willing to bend over
backwards to support
and help people
achieve things and have successes on
their stations
there's been many many
kitchens and times and days that i was
running the kitchen and a cook would
have a really bad night and they would
go they would go down and it would not
be pretty and go down you mean like go
down in flames yeah go down in flames
and you know it's high pressure and i'm
i'm sure at the time i i like freaked
out and screamed probably too much but
the thing that i made sure i did
was that at the end of the night we
would talk about it and the next day i
would show up early so that when that
person showed up
i was right there with that person we
would go over the prep list and we
together would make sure that we
wouldn't have a night like that again
because it's not good for anybody and
it's like i was invested in their
success and i think that that's that's
one nugget of what i would say to answer
your question
what
were or are
some of the most common reasons for
someone
kind of crumbling under pressure right
when they have a bad night and they just
collapse like psychologically or
otherwise yeah
what are the most common reasons for
that
mostly it's their inability to like
control their thinking because you like
this notion of getting flustered it's
like you come in at one and you prep as
hard as you can to be ready at six right
and then you're like okay i got through
the first part of the day and then
and then it's like the tickets start
rolling in
and then come seven seven thirty it
really [ __ ] starts happening and
i think keeping your compo like people
lose their composure and they get
flustered yeah and then it's just like a
landslide right and then you just go
down and that's the most common thing i
think in my opinion obviously sometimes
people just aren't ready and they aren't
they don't have the skills required but
more often it's a mind game i think
so it's just
panic basically yeah they panic and then
they lose the ability to execute on the
skills they actually do have
yes exactly it's a focus it's an
exercise in focus
maybe you could tell me a story from
your experience there has to there have
to be you can't control the whole
kitchen right or i should say rather
let's say you're a line cook
so you're not top dog and you're in a
situation where
oh [ __ ] you know it's going down like
sarah tony called in sick last minute
this is a tuesday night it's not
supposed to be big we've got like 50
menus up at the same time
uh [ __ ] and like everybody ordered the
roast chicken or whatever right yep
and you're like this is gonna be a
[ __ ] 12-car pile up and and things
start going sideways
can you tell a story of like pulling out
of a tailspin
or like what you do in a situation like
that yeah in your own head right like
what your self-talk is when that stuff
is starting to unfold you know it's wild
tim it's like that that scenario that
you paint it's kind of like an every
single night scenario when you're
running like a busy restaurant in new
york city so it's not like an outlier of
a situation
because every night in a really busy
restaurant i mean i'll speak to my
experience in new york city
you get punched in the face every single
night because like you serve 220 you
know people want to eat between 7 30 and
8 45
and or 9 and um and that happens every
single night so so it's not much of an
outlying experience but i'll i'll tell
you you've heard the word misenplace
right so to win the battle
more than half of it is
is to make sure
you're listed out early you get in and
you win the prep half of the game like
the world of cooks and kitchens are too
it's like two halves of the game there's
the first half which is up to i was just
going to say for people who don't so
mison plus or mis
is
correct me wrong it's it's it's
basically having everything prepped and
in its proper place
so that you can
execute when it comes time to actually
cook is that accurate yeah every bit of
everything that you need needs to be in
the right place and that's not just the
food ingredients but it's like the pots
and the pans and the plates and the
spoons
it's it's the tools in addition to all
the food stuffs so it's kind of it's
like a holistic picture of everything i
mean one could even say your cup of
water that you need is part of your
meson plus
yeah and i interrupted you though you
were saying the first half of the game
in the restaurant world there's two
halves of the game there's the prep half
that you have to get ready for when the
curtain goes up and then then guests are
coming through the door and that's the
beginning of the second half and
inevitably
you know because people have their
habits and you can't change it i mean
i've been i've been wishing that people
would eat at six o'clock for like 15
years of my life um but they don't so
the second half is service and
inevitably you get pummeled in the
middle and you need to be able to get to
the other side of that and not get
overwhelmed by the stacking up of
tickets
and it might sound basic
and you'll probably squeeze some more
detail out of me but it's just like
there's no better time than in the shits
to
step back and
take this approach of one ticket at a
time yeah because like you will get to
the other side of it and you just
i i kind of always love those moments
because it's like you go into this state
of focus
and i don't want to over dramatize it
but it really does become sort of a
dance you know you're in your head and
you're just doing this stuff and you're
putting up this beautiful food and it's
kind of you know it always resonated
with me i love it and and you got to get
into into the zone you know
what type of
mentorship or
boss have you
most flourished under it doesn't have to
be a specific name it could certainly
but
you know one thing i i certainly wonder
about this may be a whole separate topic
but
if
the kind of demanding
sort of chef
culture can exist today
in
in some form right it just seems like
there must be so many land mines and i'm
not saying look there's also a lot of
bad behavior all over the place so we
don't have to get into that but it makes
me think of like for instance jeffrey
our friend jeffrey zarofsky told me a
story i don't think he would mind me
telling it where he was working for some
french chef and very demanding guy
and uh but very gifted very good at
teaching
and
jeffrey was uh
he was always in the way right he was
like he's he just like could not figure
out where to put himself where he wasn't
[ __ ] everything up and so this guy
would say to me go
jeffy you are like my dick always
between my legs and i thought that was
the funniest thing i'd ever heard
like you can't you can't really do they
probably can't really do that now uh
i'm not saying you should but it is
pretty funny uh
and
so i'm i'm curious though for you
personally because different people
thrive under different styles like yeah
what type of styles have you
thrived under would you say
it's interesting in my case tim because
i spent most of my career as kind of
like
the kind of chef in charge if you will
like there was very few years at
gramercy tavern where i was under people
tom colicchio who's a mentor of mine
he was very hands-off like he really he
gave me
all the space i needed and carte blanche
to do kind of whatever i want and the
way
you know the way he
infused himself was very
very in the shadows and it wasn't
aggressive so like i think for me like i
respond best to
people that show that show me
confidence and faith right so like that
i i
i did as well as i did at gramercy
tavern
because
the hires up there
allowed me
the room
to like kind of grow and shine
in the process of doing some homework
for this conversation which i always
enjoy doing with friends because it'd be
super creepy and weird if i was like hey
i spent like five hours you know doing
internet research on you
but i have the excuse when we have these
conversations so i read that when you're
starting out now i don't know if
starting out is quite the right way to
put it but you made a list of
say five restaurants in new york city
that you wanted to work
for or at
and you kind of started knocking on
doors with a suit and the whole nine
yards right and that you and that you
ended up
at
gramercy tavern
so how did you end up
not only at gramercy tower so i want to
hear the story of like selection how did
you choose those restaurants
and then
we could this can wait until later but
separately once you landed there
how were how did you
have free reign why would anyone give
you free reign in such a situation
so there you go i started as a line cook
on gramercy tavern with no free reign
but i got to a sous chef position in
like a year
the first year i had to like prove my
merit and i was very nervous because i
hadn't worked in any any great kitchens
but i was very determined and and
so it took me a year to get to that
place where i got some freedom
is that fast
yes
okay we're gonna come back to the
restaurant selection but let's focus on
this for a second yeah now
i will accept hard work but the fact of
the matter is a lot of people work hard
a lot of people put in a lot of time
that can't be the only explanation
why
were you able to do that within a year
how did you approach it differently or
what did you do that other people didn't
do it was like every waking hour i was
thinking about it right so it's like and
i tell cooks this today you know part of
your success is not only during the
hours you walk through this door it's
like you have to you know i
was
obsessed
and i was determined to not fail
and that drove me to
kind of
read and think and make lists
outside of the restaurant so that when i
walked into the restaurant
i had
i you know not only a list of what to do
but i had it like plotted on a timeline
so that
i would be really efficient with the
four or five hours i had leading up into
into like show time right so gotta see
you know you never showed up and then
figured out what you were gonna do you
showed up with like a schedule and
agenda for
prep time a timeline schedule and like
yeah and it's like you know
there's like downstairs is where you
prep and where the walk-in boxes are and
upstairs where the kitchen is and like i
would watch i would watch cooks go up
and down the stairs because they forgot
this and that and the other thing and i
was like poor time management buddy
you're failing because you're not doing
the work pre
and you're going up and down the stairs
all [ __ ] day and like that's why
you're always not ready at six o'clock
yeah
so this attention to detail around
not only the list of things but also
plotted on a timeline
really served me well
i feel like that going up and down the
stairs
all [ __ ] day
is like a great metaphor
for people to use and like i wrote it
down for myself i'm like you know i'm
thinking to myself like where am i
running up and down the stairs all day
exactly am i going between like six tabs
constantly all the [ __ ] time like if
so why am i doing that right you know
like what am i doing am i like opening
and closing my laptop
17 times a day if so like what what's
happening there it adds up it's a
[Music]
very good question okay so you said
lists
you said you read
does reading mean and i imagine a part
of it is getting familiar obviously with
the the menu for that evening so that
you have everything that you need
any other types of reading it was just
immersing myself in food culture
and like food magazines at the time i
mean it was kind of before
the crazy digital world we live in today
so it was like
i was so in love with
the dining scene the restaurant scene
the food scene
plating food
seasonal ingredients it was kind of like
deeply embedded in my soul and it's all
it was like singularly focused right
i was singularly focused and to this day
i commiserate with my wife and i'm like
you know i'm the opposite of a
renaissance man tim like i have been
embedded
in the world of restaurants and food and
cooking for my entirety of my adult life
and it hasn't really afforded me
the ability to like dive into other
especially deeply dive into other
pursuits and and that's fine with me i'm
not begrudging it it's just
i think one of the keys to success in
the world of restaurants and cooking and
chefing is
is this all in type attitude
yeah one thing that's always impressed
me about you and honestly there's
there's part of me that's really
envious
of this
covet sounds too weird but
i do
have this kind of pang of
envy when
we're texting or talking
because god you know it's got to be
coming up on
10 years if not just past 10 years now
that we've you know first met which is
[ __ ] bonkers to think about yeah it
is way it's more than 10 for sure it's
definitely more than ten yeah and
uh when i ask you what you're up to what
you're excited about
very often i mean there are other things
of course but very often you're like
yeah i'm super stoked about like yeah
cooking this and i'm doing this and like
have this garden and like yeah you are
as excited as i have ever seen you
about
good
food and
making good food yeah when you're home
right i mean it's so
refreshing to see in a sense because i'm
what i am used to very often is like
someone who is
you know and this includes many people
who are successful in whatever given
field is like they have their thing they
do for work
and when they are not working the last
thing they would ever want to do is more
of what they consider their work right
but that's not you that's that
definitely does not seem to be you no
and you know in my later years it's like
i'm on this mission to spread the gospel
of cooking i think that
it's one of the most valuable
things one can teach themselves and i i
do
i do more cooking at home today than i
do in the restaurant
and yeah the the wonderful thing about
food and cooking
and the way
and the reason why it could become
all-encompassing
is because it's like it's that act that
we all do so it's like my daughters need
to eat every day i need to eat every day
everyone needs to eat well not every day
we all some people have fasting
practices but you get the idea and it's
ever-changing and it's constantly
dynamic and it just it it never ceases
to feed
my soul it never does
yeah it's incredible
so bookmark coming back to bookmark i
promised i would cover this with people
and i want to know selecting those
five or so restaurants where you put on
your god knows what that i would love to
see a photo of that suit back in the day
so you put on your suit and you go to
knock on some doors and smile for the
record i also had hair to my ass
and i didn't know what to do with it
because i was like what am i going to do
with my hair like going into these
interviews so my girlfriend at the time
convinced me that the best approach
would just do a single braid down the
back of my head so i was like in a suit
with a single braid like to the back of
my you know to the to my waist
so yeah it was quite something and like
the list was formed in my apartment in
san francisco because i was living in
san francisco at the time um
and my girlfriend had gotten accepted to
nyu
film school i was like in my late 20s
and i was like okay well up until now
cooking has just been a means to like
for i loved it and i was good at it but
it was never i never thought seriously
about what a career would look like
so that was a big that was a big moment
moving back to new york and deciding
that this was going to be my career
and you know the list was really
at the time gourmet magazine did
restaurant reviews
and
and i had a stack of them because i
subscribed to it
so basically i looked at the restaurant
reviews over the last like nine months
and took notes looked at the new york
times reviews took some notes
and then you know based on my own
what i was
excited about that drove the list so i
wanted it to be kind of italian-ish i
wasn't super interested in the
old-school french
restaurants uh i was interested in kind
of
fresher vegetable type so i diane
foreign had a restaurant
called verbena and she got a lot of play
for
working with botanicals and vegetables
and that was her big stick and i was
really turned on by that and um lydia
bastianich had her fancy italian
restaurant felida
and that spoke to me and i was excited
about that and then
tom danny meyer and tom colicchio
partnered and danny just did union
square and tom had an italian bent so
that kind of appealed to me so yeah i
kind of got to the city with this list
and and hit the streets like old school
style
with my resume and my suit and my my
single braid to my ass
so what was your pitch
yeah it was tough because i didn't have
a whole lot to go on i had worked at a
few restaurants here and there but like
i you know i
i had a business degree from pace
university and i worked in a handful of
restaurants that nobody ever heard of
so my pitch was i'm ready to commit to
this as my life
and i want to find the right place
that i could really learn and and really
dive into and like the pitch was this
idea of selling
these folks on
the level of commitment i would have if
they were to hire me
okay that's super interesting right
because i'm imagining you're going
through
this these reviews right in gourmet
magazine
and at the time
this is probably 2010 2011 and i know
kovid may have affected things but you
know i wrote
and just saying this to provide some
context for folks for sure all right
so in the four-hour chef you know wrote
all about
my first real
inebriated five and a half hour orgy of
gastronomic delights
and at the end of that section i said by
the end of the evening i concluded what
many others had hearth is the most
underrated restaurant all of new york
city this is saying a lot in a city with
24 000 restaurants so there are
no matter how you slice it we could
debate the number but there are a lot of
restaurants in new york city and you
have just
picked a couple of the hottest
restaurants
you can't be the only person knocking on
doors
right
and so i'm thinking to myself well wait
a second now
you know you're going to
sort of if we're thinking of it almost
like college admissions you're going to
like
harvard yale princeton you're like hey
let me in okay
the percentage of the time they say yes
has got to be pretty low because it's
not like they're going to have 70 people
working as line cooks yeah
so if i were in their shoes and you
offered that i would have to i would
think i would have to have a high degree
of confidence that you could at least
handle the work that i would be throwing
at you right
but i understand the commitment was kind
of first and foremost right this is the
commitment that i
that i plan to give if you were to hire
me what else was there to the pitch that
would
help them say yes the beauty about that
world at that time is you come in and
you do what they call a trail
a trail t-r-a-i-l yeah a trail and this
happened pretty much everywhere they
were kind of like well you know
they didn't say this but like your
resume is not that impressive and why
don't you come in and suit up and just
hang out and watch and that's common
practice i mean not so much today
because the hr stuff that we alluded to
earlier but like yeah you come in and
you spend a full day in the kitchen you
suit up and they get us you know the
people
the cooks and the sous chefs and the
chefs they get a sense of like your vibe
and your energy and your ability to just
kind of navigate a kitchen you know it's
kind of like when you said jeffrey
zyrowski was always in the way of the
chef right like part of what you need to
do on your trail is you need to be adept
to the movement of a kitchen and show
them that you're not like a deer in
headlights not knowing where to [ __ ]
stand
do you know what i mean what now are you
just like
playing tag where you're like avoiding
anyone touching you or do you have
responsibilities are you just sort of
the ghost they're like we don't want to
hear you we don't want to see you like
be a ninja that's the thing like you
need to have a good eq and you need to
go in there and you need to figure out
when it's okay to poke and try to work
and can i lend a hand or when it's time
to be quiet and be in the corner and so
so a lot of it is an is nuance and you
need to be able to read the situations
because maybe the first two hours of the
prep day
is very different than
the first hour of when the [ __ ] hits the
fan right so you need to have sense
about you and that that helps kind of
guide whether
they're going to make a decision to hire
you or not right so i've had trails who
are like absolutely useless
and and they didn't know where to stand
they didn't know when it was the right
time to help or not help and at the end
of that the cooks are like who was that
freakazoid
please don't hire him or you know or the
cooks and the sous chefs are like
wow that guy was really helpful or that
girl that was really helpful and that's
what it's about during a trail and i did
well during my trail because i was
offered a job
do they give you any direction
beforehand are they just like hey come
trail
wink wink and the understanding is like
i want to see if you can figure out when
and how to help it's kind of like unsaid
but like there's a little of course
there's a little bit of guidance like
they got to show you where the chef
whites are and changing there and like
we'll start your day here so there's
some guide rails for sure
but generally i mean i know my approach
is to say less because it's a better
test
say less to the person who asks you for
a trail yeah when the trail comes into
our kitchen i try to not
set up too much of a framework because i
think it speaks to
their level of like
ability adaptability adaptability
and ability and to follow cues if you
will as i think about my future tim and
the fact that i'm in my early 50s and
like
you know through my 60s it's like i
really i wanna i really wanna figure out
a way to teach people to cook
um because
i believe in the power of cooking so
much and
and it's the thing that i know how to do
best and like i love the process of
teaching i love what it does for
somebody when they learn how to cook
because it like
there's implications to being a good
cook that
wide implications so like to one's own
health
and to one's ability to connect
with the people under their roof or the
people they love
and there's just so much to be gained
from
devoting some time and energy into
learning how to cook and i want that to
be kind of my next phase mission in life
i endorse that i endorse that
wholeheartedly and
you think a lot about nutrition i mean
this is
uh i think in part how jeffrey initially
connected us is because
of kind of four hour body slow carb diet
and and so on i see a bullet here in
front of me in my prep nuts that i want
to ask you about and we're going to move
all over the place obviously but
that is the way my brain functions or
dysfunctions malfunctions
uh
recent 45-day
cgm that's continuous glucose monitor
experience
why did you decide to use a continuous
glucose monitor and what did you learn
from that experience
why because
i i'm kind of a bit obsessed over like
the physiology
of my own body and what and what are the
things that drive that physiology
whether it be sleep or cold plunging or
fasting or diet and
having the ability to
test and learn around my dietary choices
wasn't so intriguing to me and
once it was available and i knew it was
out there
i reached out to
frank litman who's a doctor i kind of a
friend and a doctor that i go to see in
new york
and he he figured out a way to get a cgm
on my arm and uh
so i did it just sheer at a sheer
curiosity and and a desire to just kind
of like
you know it's so cliche to say this but
just kind of optimize my diet a bit and
understanding blood sugar i totally buy
in to
level blood you know keeping blood sugar
levels
steady
i think is hugely critical to all kinds
of health
so what did you learn what were the
biggest takeaways i'll tell you the
craziest biggest takeaway that i feel
like
should be on that billboard you might
ask me about you know it won't but but
it's like take a walk after you eat
it is astonishing how can it be that
i've never heard that in my whole life
yeah
that should be like taught in first
grade because the effect of it the
effect of it is insane and and i saw it
firsthand
and i think that the folks at levels are
seeing it more and more and more because
it's get this message is getting out as
they accumulate data but the power of a
14-minute walk
to
reduce the spike of your blood sugar
regardless of what you eat
is
extraordinary wow no kidding and so you
used levels in this experiment i did
that's incredible why 14 minutes
is that the length of your favorite guns
and roses no i'm just did i say 14 or 50
15 just like a short a short me you know
just a little walk
10 minutes maybe five minutes i didn't
really test the length of the walk but
it's like it was nothing severe it was
just that exercise it's not like going
to the gym or doing push-ups just going
for a walk around the block yes totally
chill
walk around the block
and i couldn't believe it and
it's it's amazing to me so
highly highly
recommend that it should be taught
everywhere because it's incredibly
effective
that's wild man you know i haven't
thought you just prompted something to
come to my mind which i haven't thought
of
in a few decades and i'm going to
apologize to anyone who hears this and
unders kind of understands what i'm
saying uh because i'm going to probably
butcher it because my tones are off
these days but there's a there's a i
want to say well maybe it's not so much
a proverb it's a
expression in mandarin chinese which is
something like
fun ho by buddha
which is
if you walk 100 steps after you eat you
will live to be 99.
that's literally the expression that's
amazing
yeah and it's just like huh turns out a
few thousand years of
trial and error yeah how did you find
that expression tim i mean i was living
in china and uh i this is a long time
ago i mean this is 1996.
so this is back when beijing was like
people's liberation green army jackets
in the winter these green jackets and
bicycles right so beijing is a different
city now and
i was there for six months to
universities
and
i mean that was kind of the last time i
studied chinese was around that time
but
you just saying that prompted that to
pop up in my brain which is wild i'm
telling you there's a lot there's a lot
there for sure i mean that was my
experience and many others and it's just
i find it fascinating and
sitting here in 2021 and like i've been
kind of
embedding myself and trying to learn
about
you know nutrition and and health and
you know we we have some mutual friends
and people we follow and uh and it's
just amazing to me that i've never
i've never come across that
yeah how wild what else any other
insights
that you gleaned from your experiment
yep the other big one was to combine the
macronutrients like if you if you just
eat us if you just eat a carb or a a
complex carb or a simple carb by itself
as opposed to eating it alongside fat
and protein
so this idea of like a well-rounded
plate
that made a huge difference as well and
one night in particular i uh it was it
was a fun it was a fun game too having
this thing on my arm by the way so one
night i you know i went and i had a
business dinner at hearth and um
and i was kind of like i approached it
with this idea of like you know what i'm
gonna do i'm gonna like eat everything
and i'm gonna eat a lot of it right so i
went kind of nuts and i just ate all the
things like garlic breads and wine and
cocktails and and desserts and like i
just i probably consumed 3000 calories
right and i was like i want to see if i
could make my levels like blow up and
the astounding thing was because it was
like a lot of fiber and a lot of protein
and a lot of fat in addition to all the
bad simple carbs and sugars and wines
and all that i didn't spike that high
and i think it's because
having fiber and having fat and having
protein alongside
these bad players of simple carbs and
sugar
helps mitigate that spike
huh did you exercise earlier in the day
by any chance do you know yeah my
exercise is always i don't i'm i'm uh
i'm a exercise first thing kind of guy
yep although my lifestyle is active
because i live in you know in new york
i'm always on my feet and i'm walking a
lot right so
that must play into things as well
fascinating it was i loved having that
thing on my arm i kind of want to do it
again
because
there's so much cool testing and
learning you can do
yeah you can do some cool stuff i'm
gonna do another cgm
experiment soon because the last time i
did a continuous glucose monitor
experiment was in 2008 or nine for the
four hour body
with the version one dexcom which you
had to implant in your abdomen which i
had to basically get off the back of a
truck meaning like through
gray area means because it was only
intended for type 1 diabetics and you
couldn't get it otherwise
and it there was an external
screen slash device that you would hang
on your belt like a beeper there was no
iphone
and uh it was
very much different experience gen one
yeah and uh
it'll be much more interesting to
do now with the vastly improved
technology and
you know i'm so curious to see
my takeaways because
the tools are just so much better and i
have more tools right because i have
sure the aura ring which i wear for
sleep i have eight sleep which i use to
cool my bed typically
and you know i noticed something just in
this last week and i was like wow that's
really
wild i still need to replicate it but
a i've noticed and i knew this already
but that the the most obvious takeaway
from the aura ring is if you drink
certain types of booze past a certain
point your sleep is just garbage it's
like so clear especially deep sleep
totally however what i noticed
when looking at my recovery and sleep
scores on the aura
as an experiment recently you know i had
two
large glasses of wine rose in this case
and that that is usually enough to
completely destroy my sleep but what i
decided to do
was to decrease the temperature of my
bed more than usual to turn down the
temperature because one of the symptoms
of drinking too much alcohol is my
resting body temperature goes up at
night yep
so i did that
for those who have an eight sleep i went
from like a negative three in the
beginning to a negative four and that
would usually kind of ascend up to
waking
so i lowered it let's just call it
33
right
and or an additional kind of 33
and
what i found was i woke up feeling much
more refreshed and my numbers on the
aura ring look totally different so i
need to replicate it that's incredible
it's super interesting as a hypothesis
to be like okay if i suppress some of
the symptoms
of alcohol consumption which would so
some of the symptoms would include lower
heart rate variability right so normally
i'd be like 33 to 40.
i guess it's milliseconds
i think it's ms is the sort of increment
i'm not sure actually what the unit is
but so the 33 to 40
on the aura ring
if i drink it drops down to like low to
mid 20s so that would be one symptom
another symptom would be the higher
temperature higher resting heart rate
and it's hard to know if all these
symptoms happen simultaneously or if
some of those phenomena
cause the others right like so for
instance does the elevated temperature
then result in the lower
heart rate variability right
at the very least i mean it's kind of an
interesting idea because i don't drink a
lot these days because i feel it much
more as i've grown older yep but i enjoy
it i'm not gonna lie i know it's very
out of vogue and it's like you know the
uh
all the hip kids are like i'll just do
ketamine i'm like well i don't know um
you know maybe a time and a place but i
still like my wine with friends you know
i don't want to be a truffle pig
snorting ketamine at the dinner table so
the
the idea that you have these tools and
if you're able to form a hypothesis and
then try to replicate it which is super
important right so it's easy to fool
yourself yeah is super exciting and like
the take a walk after you eat right
because i could look at okay
because i have noticed that like if i'm
gonna drink
if i give my body four or five hours to
metabolize before i go to bed my sleep
is much improved right so if i'm gonna
have three glasses of wine if i have it
at an early dinner at 5 30 yeah
i am going to be much better off all my
markers than if i have it at eight
o'clock dinner right sure so then
there's a question of like well what
happens if i still have the eight
o'clock dinner but then i go for
30 minutes let's say i i i make it
you know it could be a 10 minute walk
but it could be like a 30 minute walk
right
see how that affects things and it's
it's super tricky because like you're
sort of an amateur obviously we're all
amateur if we're doing it this way
scientists in a sense and there are a
million variables but you can start to
play with these things absolutely
one of the other things i noticed that i
found intriguing was this idea of
metabolizing alcohol and
every time i drank
i would see a blood sugar spike that
would come at like 3 30 in the morning
yeah and it's just like you hear about
the fact that it takes a while for your
liver to metabolize liquor and the
reason why
you wake up you know you you spoke about
overheating and stuff but like it's also
because that's when your liver is
finally metabolizes it and you have a
blood sugar spike and it happens like
five hours later
yeah so yeah all kinds of cool stuff
around that levels app or any cgm uh app
and yeah i'm dying to do it again and
funny i know that you're into sauna i i
actually i actually bought a barrel
sauna after i saw yours and austin but
um
i had to figure out a way to
not stop my sauna so i had a
i had a huge like
wool felt thing that i would put over my
center and then i would wrap it with
string so that would protect the center
because it doesn't like 208 degrees
so you put like a a russian bonya
wool hat on your arm
to protect that's exactly what it was
yeah and then i wrapped it that's pretty
gangster you look like some kind of i
don't know badass yeah badass like
warrior from last of the mohicans or
something that's amazing
uh great book by the way i've recently
read very dated for those people who are
sensitive to such things but beautifully
written
so let's let's jump into some nutrition
stuff and this is going to be a segue
into
uh talking about brodo which i want to
ask you about
so one thing we chatted about in your
kitchen when we were
bullshitting over tea and waiting for
the oven to eat up
was uh i think you actually brought it
up
this
book metabolical and
a quote which it's not what's in the
food it's what's been done to the food
and i think the
example you gave was some snack food
made out of chickpeas
and i would love for you to
sort of replay or just speak to that
because it highlights something that's
super super important that
i also need to think more about honestly
which is that the ingredient panels and
nutrition facts panels are just not
enough if you're trying to assess the
health value
of your food so could you speak to that
and maybe you could just use use an
example
this has been on my mind for a while
especially since i've been trying to
like build and grow the broth business
because the more i learned about the
consumer package good space
the more this came obvious and
chickpeas are a good example because
through the years i've spoken to a lot
of people trying to like
you know commercialize a packaged food
product and and the perfect
metaphor is hummus
because like
you could read an ingredient panel and
it could say
organic chickpeas and organic lemon
juice and organic whatever whatever and
it has all the buttons and
and the nutritional facts panels you
know
has what it has but
there's no way of a consumer to know
whether the person who made that hummus
boiled beans
or just got powdered chickpea and added
water
you know so like there's there's no
transparency around process in so much
of the foods that we consume another
easy one is seed oils right it's like
the process you have to put rapeseed
through to get the oil out it's like
they're washing it with chemicals hexane
and then they're putting it through a
high heat process that oxidizes the fat
and like what comes out the other end is
an oil that has residue of chemicals
that has been oxidized by the heat
where do you know that as a consumer
if you're in the aisle reading the back
label of the of the organic
canola oil or or the chick the organic
chickpea that has all the right buttons
and all the right marketing on it and
that's what's been driving me for six
years i want to get a traditionally made
broth out to the masses and like that's
really hard to do like the world
the food system we live in today there's
a lot of room for improvement and it's
going to be a long hard battle but it's
like i'm not afraid of long hard
anything so i'm really willing to go
after it
but yeah transparency i guess to put it
in a little bullet it's like
there is no transparency around the
process
and that's a big problem as we
navigate the food world
yeah and to build on that you know there
are
cases where you can sort of deduce that
a does not equal a in quotation marks in
the sense that
if you buy hummus from the farmer's
market with a certain set of ingredients
and then you go to the the
sort of hipster grocery store and you
find
chickpea
crisps
that are completely different texture
completely different form factor are
shelf stable for 175 years
not to say that's true for all crisps
i'm just making up an kind of arbitrary
example
you can safely assume that something has
been done to the ingredients that was
not done at the farmers market and it's
just unclear what has been done but
there has been some level of
manipulation for it to take a different
form right that's just how it has to
has to be
now in in notes here
i wasn't aware of this but apparently
there's a nova classification
do you want to describe what this is the
nova classification system developed by
researchers at university of sao paulo
yeah so and i'd like to believe that
this is the future for us as well
because like i think consumers
we're just
we're getting smarter and smarter and
we're caring more and more about
the things that really drive health and
that
i mean i think it's unquestionable that
the choices we make daily about what we
eat and drink is like the biggest driver
of health
and so i'd like to believe there will be
a time where
the big food companies will have to be
more transparent around the process
and the nova system is
is happening in south america and
it basically
it basically
sets
four categories of like
ultra process processed
um i can't remember the other two names
but basically it provides a framework
to define
what foods are ultra processed
as opposed to process
as opposed to like culinary ingredients
that are minimally processed
yeah it looks like
so to
summarize that the nova classification
system which was developed in brazil by
researchers
defines separates out food into four
groups based on the level of processing
so the first level is unprocessed
the second is processed culinary
ingredients right
do you say culinary or culinary what do
you say i say culinary
god damn it all right
so
processed culinary ingredients
the third is processed and then the
fourth is ultra processed right and yeah
this is so important and there are you
know a lot of
questions that
you know unfortunately seem to add a lot
of complexity to the
lives of and consumers right because
they're like good god can i just know
that a [ __ ] banana is a banana for
god's sake you know right
but there are certain questions that
i think are worth asking right like so
how like how processed if you had to put
it i don't actually i'm not totally
clear on unprocessed and then processed
culinary ingredients versus processed
maybe you can tell me what the
difference is between processed culinary
ingredients and processed i don't know
do you have any idea what that means
well culinary ingredients are things
that you would find in a kitchen pantry
as opposed to a food scientist pantry in
a in a food manufacturing plant right so
when i cook at home i don't have a
pantry full of emulsifiers or
stabilizers or so i think it's like this
notion of culinary ingredients is like
the things that you would imagine like
spices and herbs and
dried tomato and think flour
yeah yeah yeah got it okay and look i i
just want to say like there's a lot of
ambiguity around a word like processed
right because everything is somewhat
processed and like i think that's what
nova is trying to parse that a bit
codify it yeah yeah to define it right
well it's just like
if people say
our food is all natural it's like okay
right let's take a look at what that
means right and i'm by no means an
expert in the nova system i just wanna i
i wanted to bring it up because
i believe it's where we're going in the
space and i believe it's needed
and and i haven't really vetted or done
a lot of uh reading around nova but i
just i like it conceptually because
it's a huge gap
yeah
yeah for sure i mean i think the the
processing question is is a huge blind
spot
for
for people another blind spot which we
don't have to dwell on but it's
something i think about a lot is
thinking about what
you
what you eat
ate if that makes any sense so people
say like like you are what you eat and
it's like well you got to go a step
further like
you are what you eat
yeah like your food that you are eating
what nourished that right because if
it's some if you're like hey i'm
eating
fish
and that is so much healthier than
beef you gotta double click on that and
take a look because if it's some like
really disgusting
industrial level
farming operation where they're just
dumping food and
pet and
antibiotics and so on into the water
they've basically taken the worst
practices of terrestrial agriculture and
just poured it into the water right so
you have
you have to look a lot and then if you
compare that to just say like
grass-fed grass-finished beef
putting aside
i mean environmental concerns for the
moment because i think you know both can
be degrading but
if we're just looking at individual
health right those those are very
different from
uh
say industrial level
cattle farming versus
you know different source of salmon
right and by the way this isn't just
limited to
animals right it's also true of of of
plant matter right yes fertilizers and
like how much yeah the the nutrient
density of the soil that the the the
vegetables were grown in right yeah yeah
exactly right i mean are we dealing with
like a few inches of topsoil with like
tons of fertilizer poured on top of it
or
are we talking about something else
i happen to be fascinated by this stuff
so i don't mind digging into it but it's
really unfortunate that it's
so it's so complex in part because
there's so many incentives to hide this
kind of [ __ ] exactly you know what i
mean yeah there's so many incentives
because if a company can get you
something bigger faster cheaper
and
leave the details off of the packaging
of course
they're going to be a lot of people are
going to take that so let's let's talk
about let's talk about brodo so you
unlike many restaurants you were open
throughout the entire
pandemic is is my understanding and i
didn't know that until we just recently
spent time together
i was kind of afraid to ask honestly
because of so many horror stories that
i've heard
and
love you love the restaurant and i'm
ashamed of that so i'm sorry that i you
know
didn't ask but i was just like oh god
like i can only imagine how hard it must
be and i was afraid to ask but the fact
of the matter is
you
you kept the broto window open you sold
frozen foods you also
i don't want to say liquidated maybe you
did but you you realize that you had all
of this
valuable inventory of wine and so sold
wine
and you were able to kind of figure it
out so i think that's
it's just incredible and inspiring
i don't know if you'd like to add
anything to that i just wanted to sort
of preface
the discussion of of brodo with that
that is sort of uh
a great metaphor in a way also yeah that
that window ended up being like the
portal in the lifeline it's what allowed
us to stay open because you know we were
mandated by the city that if you serve
you know if you were a sit-down
restaurant like you couldn't stay open
if you wanted you had to close and
that's what hearth was
and it was the fact that i had a brodo
window
selling these hot cups of broth out of a
little window it was like a little
lifeline that allowed the entire
restaurant to kind of stay open
kovit as hard as it was tim
um
it was an incredible it was an
incredible 16 18 i mean we're still in
it but it was an incredible
time for the restaurant and the team
because like
you know the small group of us that came
together to keep that place alive it was
like everybody thought outside of the
box everybody did things and learned
things that they didn't know before and
the fact that we all came together
and did all of these fun creative
things to stay relevant and to find some
revenue we all thrived on it so it was
like as hard as it was it was like it
really engaged us all in a way that we
hadn't been after you know because the
restaurant's 17 years old so it was like
a really nice swift kick in the ass that
got us thinking in a way that we
wouldn't have because as you know
something that's 16 years old you're in
the groove you know yeah and then kovitt
came and turned everything upside down
and it was
it was kind of thrilling
well long and hard you're not afraid of
long and hard yeah
uh yeah you're you're like surfing that
you're very accustomed to kind of
surfing paddling out and surfing under
foot waves which is just wild and why
don't we why don't we take a
step back and
i would love for you to tell the story
of how brodo came to be sure broto's
turned into one of those things i look
forward to when i visit new york city
and
i remember some very early
super early taste tests
where i had like just fyi like you're
one of the first people i called
when
i kind of realized that the launch of
the broto window out of the side door of
hearth
um
you know i got a sense after about two
months
that
i was kind of on to something yeah and
i poked at you
i don't know seeking advice or something
and and and i think you said something
to the effect of well marco
it's more about you needing to ask
yourself what you want
i thought was great advice you've kind
of been part of this since the beginning
you you know you were at our first shop
in the west village
i hosted you and that's when i gave you
the full broth tasting of like that
whole world of hot beverages around
broth yes
so yeah you've been right there
alongside me and i really appreciate
that
it's been fun to see its evolution i
mean i think that
on one level
the experiment with the window is a is a
beautiful case study of
low risk
entrepreneurial experimentation right
it's not like you found another retail
shop it's not like you put all of your
pushed all your chips in
on broth you're like hey
correct me if i'm wrong but you're like
you know what can we do with these
amazing ingredients that we already have
totally i understand broth
we have this location
open a window see how it does and you're
like you know if we cover our costs or
maybe make a little bit of money we're
in great shape so the downside risk is
super low
yeah and you got to test it and then
develop it and kind of start with the
basics but with really really good
ingredients again like for people
listening i think of the
gnocchi right like there's
yes okay flour and potato okay anybody
can go out and get flour and potato but
many different types of flour
many different types of potatoes
many different types of preparation
and
then when we did the taste test in the
west village i still remember that
because i you know i love bone broth and
uh
even i got to a point where i was like
maybe i need to slow down on today's
intake of bone broth because i had like
a gallon
of bone broth and it was amazing i
couldn't stop myself but what were the
flavors that we tested that day do you
remember we had tonka that was one look
i probably forced the entire menu down
your gullet so the top five are the
deeply rooted um which is fresh turmeric
and ginger
inside of um you know we have four
different broths so i probably i
probably gave you these combos
in a variety of different base broths
but definitely you got the deeply rooted
you got the spicy nona which is uh some
calabrian chili and roasted garlic puree
like buzzed in
um
the tom yum which is coconut and lime
and chili and a little bit of curry
powder you definitely got that you got
my favorite one which is the oishi oishi
which you know better than i do what
that means but that's tasty right oyster
oyster yeah yeah oic
yeah
and that is um a little bit of shiitake
tea and grass-fed butter and garlic
buzzed into broth
so you had them all i probably made you
at the time what i called the flu
fighter because like i'm a bit obsessed
with mortar and pestles and the flu
fighter is basically fresh ginger
fresh turmeric peppercorns
some fresh oregano
all pounded to a paste and then i add a
little grass-fed butter pound it into
the butter and then you take that
mixture and you
you burn mix it into really hot broth
uh also some chili in there for heat
yeah and a big squeeze of lemon but
anyway it's it's an incredibly
restorative
beverage that flu fighter and just broth
in general is just like it's so
you know the thing the thing about
brodo for me tim is
it's the perfect distillation
of the simplicity that i've been seeking
my whole life
and i felt like broto is the perfect
is the perfect thing to try to bring to
the masses because
it really in a way
is the simplicity i've been grasping for
throughout my whole career
so
to that point
right and i'm excited about this
obviously i got a preview when we were
when we were making the gnocchi
or before we started making the gnocchi
that's having more coffee
uh i got to see a preview because you
can't serve the world through
a window
in new york city right so so what is the
the latest and greatest
i know this is a sort of a bit a big big
step so what
what is going on
with brodo well you know brodo is what
they call right now you know much to the
chagrin of many people i get in front of
as i try to raise money but uh we're an
omni channel business so we have shops
that i really love and i'm really proud
of um kovid kind of pressed pause on the
shops for a bit
but like i do believe that we could have
a shop for every 50 starbucks in the
world because broth as a hot beverage is
incredible there's a lot to it and i
would put it up against coffee any day
of the week um so i'm very excited at
pursuing shops that's one piece of our
business
and then brodo.com is another big piece
of our business
where we sell our base broth and then
the other part of the business which i
think of what you're alluding to is our
new our new product launch that we're
really excited about um which is we
finally figured out a way to get these
shop drinks i.e the deeply rooted the
spicy nona the tuscan sun
tom yum etc into a single serve format
full strength in frozen so it's like
you're gonna be able to get eight ounces
of these combo drinks that
you know we've been serving uh in new
york city on the shelves of uh you know
456 whole foods and it's it's certainly
not it's certainly it's been it's been a
beast to get into whole foods and get
the manufacturing and you know and and
and i won't bore people with that stuff
unless you want more but uh anyway
we finally after six years
are getting these combo broth beverages
out into the world in a real way and
we're super stoked yeah i saw the
packaging which is gorgeous and
what can people
find on brodo.com
currently right so if they're
more inclined to go to a website what
are their options on broto.com
at the moment of this recording we have
22 ounce
tubs of four base broths and we have a
grass-fed beef broth we have a chicken
broth we have a vegan
shiitake and and uh seaweed broth
and then we have my favorite which is
what i call hearth broth and that's made
with uh turkey beef and chicken it's
like a combo broth um so up until now
that's what we've been we've been
selling those four skus on brodo.com
but hopefully by the time this drops to
the world
our uh we've been working on our website
and we're gonna have the new format
which is the eight ounce single serve
available in these super flavorful combo
drinks
and when you get the single serve how
many single serves are in a
case or a box
we do eight to a box
but in grocery you'll be able to buy
them individually nice
let me ask a couple of those those
closing questions
and uh and see where we go okay
so i'll start with with one
that
i know you've heard before
which is the the billboard question so
yeah
if uh if you could put anything on a
billboard
metaphorically speaking to get a quote
comment a question image anything out to
billions of people yup what might that
be i think it would be cook your own
food
i think our obsession with convenience
and our belief that we could outsource
something as important as cooking
has been one of the main drivers in the
in the ill health of this country
cook your own food
yup
dig it next question which is
most or frequently given
books so what books have you gifted
often to other people besides your own
so you know at work every year i kind of
give my uh my line cooks and my
management team books as gifts around
the holidays
so
this is water by david foster wallace is
one i commonly give because it's just
it's so short and
and the message is so
perfect in my opinion
so i i've given that a lot and then for
cookbooks
i gotta say the marcello has on
essentials is just
i i i adore i adore that woman i adore
her simple approach it is like she's the
og
of like italian grandma cooking so those
are the those are the two books
yeah marcela hazan i remember
roasted chicken i think she has i mean
she has got a lot obviously but oh my
god a ton
yeah i remember just being so impressed
with her roasted chicken especially for
young young cooks that come through my
kitchen it's just like i always ask them
i'm like do you have this book and if
they say no then i get them that book
favorite failures any favorite failures
come to mind
things that set you up for later success
or that you
you wouldn't trade in
favor it's a tough way to frame it but
like
when i opened hearth in 2003 i had a
partner a business partner and like
at year 10 that thing got dissolved
so i would say like
that first that first business
partnership failure
i don't know if i would call it a
favorite thing it was it wasn't it
wasn't a fun process but
it was a very valuable one
what did you take away from that what
did you learn from that
just to do a little bit more
inquiry
and and vetting
around common
we were so caught up in
the romantic vision and dream of what it
would mean to open our own restaurant
that we forgot to like step back and uh
you know do some work around
defining things that we should have and
it like
it got in the way and it ended poorly
but now i know better so like what else
what more can you ask for from from
learning you know when you said define
things certain things that weren't
defined are there certain things that
you would encourage people to define
that you didn't that they could consider
if they're looking at a potential
partnership
one of the pet peeves i had like a minor
thing but i think i'll mention it just
for the hell of it it's like my partner
was obsessed with riesling wine and i
was obsessed with simple italian cooking
and so my food and his wine didn't
really go well together because he was
like obsessed with riesling and i wanted
like assy chiantis on the menu and uh it
sounds minor right but that's the thing
to learn about these kinds of
partnerships whether it's romantic
partnerships or business partnerships
it's like
don't underestimate those little minor
nags because over time they become big
things
yeah that's super super important
well mr marco
i think we're coming to
the close
we're not going to talk about our sauna
oh we could talk about something we
could talk about we we could what have
you learned about your your your sauna
experiments what is your best practices
now and why
so you know i got you you are a hard
charger when it comes to saunas i mean i
do sauna as well i just did one
yesterday yeah impressed by how much of
a hard charger you are
i'm super obsessed with sauna lately and
like i i love this idea of pushing
the boundaries of what you think you're
capable of and hot and cold
is a great way to do that
and i think it just builds
it builds immense mental
capacity to deal with like hardship and
i feel like being resilient
is something that i love
the idea that i could do something that
helps me practice resilience
and you know maybe some people get that
through exercise or whatever but like
the fact that i could sit in my sauna at
210 degrees for 20 minutes
is something that i get excited about
and then and then plunging into 48
degree water after that and sitting in
that water for four minutes
um
it's just a good mind [ __ ] of a game and
i've been obsessed with it lately
and you know what do i get out of it
other than the mental exercise of
overcoming the cold and the hot
i don't know this because i don't have
an aura ring but
it really helps my sleep and it really
helps me calm down at the end of like a
stressful day
what time do you usually do
the hot cold
i usually do it after an early dinner
yeah too late and it's tough too late
and it's it's tough but
exactly on the earlier side i usually do
it before dinner but
uh
i'm uh
i've tossed my cookies from too much
heat before
but
it's so number one for everyone
listening we're not giving medical
advice these are two
whack-a-doodle
guys talking about what they do so get
proper medical clearance before you do
any extremes and hot or cold however
i will note just for people who can't
put it in context those are hot and cold
temperatures also
i have a cold plunge about 100 feet from
where i'm sitting how cold does it get
i'm not really sure i mean it's a chest
freezer full of water and ice
that is unplugged
it's unplugged at the moment my guess is
that it's it's
yeah high 30s low 40s and i will say to
anyone wondering uh
at least in my experience and the
experience of many friends on the cold
side and i'd be curious to hear your
thoughts marco but
there there isn't a sort of linear
incremental
perception to cold
in other words it's not like
going from 65 to 55 is the same as going
from 55 to 45.
once you get into
the
40s it is a different game
the perception of cold is so different
and just be aware of that before you get
in
it is chilly and uh i'm a fan i'm also
i'm also a fan of fan of both and i know
that you like pushing the edges
and you like experimentation and you
also like preserving the essence right i
mean i think that from my exposure to
you like one thing you're not a fan of
is fattish new ingredients or the quest
for
kind of magic bullet
pt barnum
components of food but
you are
all about experimentation
with
whole food ingredients i mean that's i
mean i see you conducting experiments
constantly right it's not as though
you're saying like hey this is the way
spaghetti is made this is the only way
spaghetti should ever be made
you're constantly
running experiments but it's with the
integrity of whole food
yeah as sort of like the base
of your elements that you are allowing
yourself to work with
which i admire because i think the
conceit that we would possibly
understand
everything that is going on
uh multifactorially when you eat
foods in combinations is just
at this point given our technology and
ability to assess these things pretty
ridiculous yeah we need some humility
around that for sure i mean it's like
there's so much we don't know in that
space and um
yeah i couldn't agree more tim it's like
we're learning every day and like we all
have to acknowledge that there's a lot
left to learn right and one of the
reasons why i love peter atiyah is
because he really that's like a
fundamental
kind of point that he launches off of is
this idea of like
you know i might believe this today but
i might not believe it next week yeah
and we all need to get comfortable with
that
yeah for sure it makes me think of this
story uh
you know coming back to that like the
chinese proverb right and how
much uh and who knows
very easily could just be coincidence
and maybe it's just some poor chinese
guy came up with a saying that rhymed
really nicely but
it does coincide
very well with your experience as
validated through the latest and
greatest continuous glucose monitor
right few maybe a few thousand years
separated
that's interesting right at least it
raises questions like is that just
chance or
you know have humans figured out a lot
by trial and error and in fact even our
sort of primate
predecessors figured out right because
we're not the only animals
who use say plants as medicine and
reading this book recently called
medicine quest by an ethnobotanist named
mark plotkin
and i'm hoping to excerpt some of it on
the blog because there are a few
chapters that are really just incredible
and he tells this story
of a number of
supposedly the ethnobotanists
who were working
they might have actually been at a
research institution they weren't uh
they weren't doing this for commercial
development
but there was some type of concoction
that
a you know medicine man in this case
right some type of healer which is much
more than
psychedelics and psychotropics which is
which
bothers me when the assumption is like
all these people do is dose people with
hallucinogens and they're basically
pharmacists who use the in this case the
jungle
to treat ailments of all different types
including fungal infections parasites
etc
and
if i remember correctly
these researchers were able to observe
with glucose measurements
that this concoction which included
three plants
reliably lowered
blood glucose and type 2 diabetics
and
they'd never seen these plants never
id'd this type of concoction
and
they asked this this uh this medicine
man which plants he used
and he said no problem you're welcome to
take them back and analyze them he gave
them these three plants they took them
back
they looked for
what could be active molecules
ran all sorts of tests on these three
plants
negative negative negative nothing all
three together negative and
then they went back
and
because they discarded one step and they
forgot they discarded one step and
they're like we need to watch you
prepare this oh they said your
concoction doesn't work and he goes what
do you mean my concoction doesn't work
you what you measured
the results and patients taking it how
do you how do you how do you conclude it
doesn't work and they go well we tested
them all separately we need to watch you
make it again and so they're watching
him make it
and you know he he's doing what he's
doing with the three plants and then at
the very end he drops a crab in
and they're like what was that and he's
like it's the crab
and they go
what and they go we asked you what was
in your concoction he goes no you didn't
you asked me which plants were in my
concoction oh my god that's amazing and
for some bizarre reason it changed
everything right it's like plant plant
plant crab
wow and all of it together
somehow
that was figured out to have this effect
now
putting aside
this is not randomized controlled trials
i understand that could a huge part of
it be placebo effect maybe could it be
contextual based on the culture yes but
there's so many phenomena
that we cannot explain
at this point in time it's it's just the
the pinnacle of hubris to think that we
have a full understanding of food when
we've demonstrated throughout our
history including recent history how
piss-poor we are at at deconstructing
these things so that's i'll get off my
soapbox but dude i couldn't thank you
for saying that because i couldn't have
said it better myself and it's like it's
so at the core
it's really at the core of my belief
system too and like i look backwards to
help guide my nutritional
path forward because i believe that as
well it's like i think the best trial is
looking through the history of man
not um the current state of research
science in this world yeah because it's
it's like a mess
and you can look at both but make sure
to look at both right i mean there's
another story i think this is actually
told to me if you don't mind i'm now
like on a roll just because i get so i
mean i love this stuff i get so spun up
about this stuff there's me too
so like look yes there's a lot of
superstition and [ __ ] there's a lot
of like nonsense and draws that that
humankind has accumulated yes and right
now like the scientific method is
the best way we have
consistently of asking questions of
nature and trying to sort answers out
without fooling ourselves so i i
i mean i fund a lot of science so i
believe that
a lot of the funding is bogus i'm sorry
to interrupt you tim because you're on a
thing but it's like it's worth noting
that
it's important to follow the money of
the funding and one of the things i
respect and admire about you and the
things that you fund and peter atiyah
and the way he goes through world and
life around research is you have to ask
those really hard questions yeah like
you read the studies but it's hard to
follow and analyze and understand
who did the studies and where the
money's coming from and and it's a big
red flag a lot of times oh yeah yeah and
so
100 agree with that and you know
for-profit companies will establish
foundations and institutes and all sorts
of weird stuff to hide sources of
funding for sponsored research or
studies
they're all so yes there's a lot of bad
behavior right you'll have people fund
20 studies and
18 of them will say this stuff is
terrible for you two will say it's good
for you they'll be like great we'll take
those two thanks very much
uh there's a lot of bad behavior you
should always look at the conflicts of
interest sections and so on
yeah with all of those warts
science and the scientific method's
still very important however we assume
we know more than we do
this is true of of humans for as long as
we've called ourselves humans and one
story that i remember a friend told me
who did a lot of work in uh
in i believe it was south
america but it may have been africa and
he said you know we
went with this ngo to help this this
this local group and
they had really low yield well like
moderate yield on a crop and they always
put it
way up on the hillside and we asked them
why they put it way up on the hillside
i'm paraphrasing this but it's something
like this
and they said well that's because that's
the way our you know grandparents did it
and then why did they do it that way
well that's the way their grandparents
did it and so these uh you know
bright-eyed bushy-tailed like 20 and 30
somethings and this ngo are like oh well
we have some news for you like it'd be
you'd have much better yield if you did
it like down in the valley and did it
this way in that way based on modern
agriculture and what we know about a b c
d e and like let us let us show you how
this is done
and uh you know these villagers are like
fantastic we'll try it and so they put
them all down in the valley
first first sort of winter storm so it
must have been yeah more central maybe
uh probably not africa uh or it was at
altitude i think and there there was
this frost that came through and like
wiped out everything
in the valley
and they're like yep turns out you
shouldn't plant [ __ ] there
so you know don't don't assume the past
is the path forward but i think it is
safe to assume that hidden amongst
the false positives and false and
negatives there's also a lot of signal
in in the past and
you know that's that's been made clear
in my adventures and conversations with
you
that's been made also super clear in
reading about and experiencing firsthand
a lot of the traditions in italy which
is a it's a great
it's a great cuisine to
study because
there is complexity
or there are nuances right but you're
not dealing with dishes
at l at least in the central and south
that have 27 ingredients generally right
like
like you're you're able to actually look
at the variables and it's so much fun
well we could go for hours i'm getting
uh i'm getting all spun up
so i'm gonna try to land this plane okay
so marco people can go and should go to
brodo.com
b-r-o-d-o.com i recommend everyone try
it they can find the restaurant at
restauranthearth.com certainly in new
york city if you're in nyc
give a visit they can find you on
instagram at marcokenora that's
m-a-r-c-o-c-a-n-o-r-a
is there anything else you would like to
say
any closing comments requests of the
audience anything at all that you'd like
to add before we wrap this up
two things and i'll be quick because
we've been going on and on but um one is
i want to just thank you for the
incredible work that you do and like
i found you many years ago and i've been
following you ever since and
you're incredibly generous and and so
thoughtful in your work and uh
i am one of many who really really
appreciates it so i want to say thank
you to you
thank you
and then no again i just i just want to
put a point on the cooking thing it's
like
cooking is is an incredible process that
engages all of your senses
that gives you a high reward from health
to flavor to community to connectivity
to other people
and it's really a path to so many of the
things that i think we need to be
better human so
i just want to encourage anybody who's
fearful of cooking
or is like i don't know if i want to do
it or not
please please do it and you will grow to
love it and it will reward you forever
here here brother you know as you're
saying that i'm like i need to go thaw
out some venison go to the farmer's
stand get some food i'm gonna cook
dinner on sunday night i'm so fired up
it's [ __ ] great man
marco
you're a mensch
i look forward to spending more time
together it's so nice to see you you too
i can't wait to visit you wherever the
hell you are
yeah wherever i will be wherever i am
for sure i can't wait
and keep going man keep going and i
recommend everybody check out again
brodo.combrodo.com check it out do a
taste test you'll thank me later
and to everybody listening
we'll have show notes links to
everything as per usual at tim.blog
podcast
and until next time thank you for tuning
in
and now we bring to you the affair of
the oven that wasn't on other mysteries
and how to make delicious gnocchi enjoy
let's talk about the the affair of the
oven that wasn't on ah
you're jumping ahead i love it i i'm
jumping ahead i'm jumping back we're
going to go all over the place i love it
so i sent you a voice memo
not too too long ago i mean this is a
few months ago
and
it was a question about
gnocchi
gnocc
for people who
don't know the spelling
and
we should we should probably describe
what gnocchi are for people who don't
know but
the reason i sent you a voice memo is i
was trying to think up a birthday gift
for my girlfriend my girlfriend is half
italian
and she and her mom have been trying to
recreate this family recipe for gnocchi
for a decade something like this maybe
more
and
there was always
something missing or something they
weren't getting right because the
gnocchi would just not turn out
so i asked you if you might
know how to make the oaky
or and if if so if you would be open to
now i said it i mean i wasn't quite that
stupid about it but i i asked you if you
might be open to
uh teaching my girlfriend and her mom
via zoom how to make gnocchi properly
and uh i really wish i had
that voice memo your response to put
into this podcast
it was great but it was basically
yes
uh i have made 10 000
plus rounds of gnocchi and it's been
featured in these following outlets and
actually quite famous for the gnocchi
and
so yes i do know how to make gnocchi
and then you very graciously offered to
teach and so i think the gnocchi
is uh is a great jumping off point
because
it offers some fertile ground for
i think a pretty hilarious story
and it also shows how
house
how simplicity and elegance can be the
byproduct of trial and error if that
makes any sense absolutely so before we
get into the stories and the
the affair of the oven that was not on
what are gnocchi just so people know
what we're talking about
uh it's a potato dumpling it's like you
know it's like a version of pasta if you
will but it's made with potato and uh
some people use egg i don't it's just
but you know
what i'm really proud of about my
approach is there's only two ingredients
and that is potato and flour
okay just so we don't kind of
bury the punch line here yeah
what are some of the keys
either the keys to making gnocchi
that are delicious and fluffy and
amazing like the ones that that we made
and by we we i mean 90 you but we
participated
or what are the common mistakes if you
could just kind of walk us through
maybe a few of the things that make
great gnocchi great and why so many
gnocchi are not great yeah
so you know look gnocchi has a bad
reputation of being super heavy right so
you eat them and they end up being gummy
and they just they're like lead in your
belly and like that's the biggest
complaint i hear most about a lot of
gnocchi out in the world so getting them
to be very light and airy is something
anybody making gnocchi should kind of
try to get to
and then you know
the flavor of the potato should come
through and that means not adding too
much stuff to it i mean i think a lot of
a lot of home chefs and and even
professional chefs
they always try to like
infuse other things and like sweet
potato gnocchi or butternut squash
gnocchi and it's like
again back to this simplicity idea it's
like no
gnocchi or made with potato sorry
so i think keeping it simple and keeping
it light is the goal
and you know some of the pitfalls is
like people add a lot of egg and i don't
think egg is necessary i mean as a
as an amateur you might want to add egg
because it'll protect you a bit and keep
it together
um but you're making a dough and that
dough should not be overworked because
you're using flour and you don't want to
you know you got to think of it like a
pie crust or a biscuit crust and you
don't want to work the gluten too much
or else they become what i said which is
like sticky and dense
so there were a few things that hopped
out
at me
and there are many things that are kind
of counter-intuitive right so one of the
first was
don't get your
sort of hipster 10 a potato potatoes
that are as fresh as possible that is a
mistake
right and in fact you kind of want the
opposite so i'd love to hear you speak
to to why that's the case sure
and then the i want to clarify and
please fact check me one thing that you
said which was
related to
i think i would imagine a common error
which is people are needing with their
hands needing with a k
the the flour into the potato but by
doing so you're kind of creating this
elastic gummy glutinous
response right and instead what i saw
you do
and we did some of this too is to use a
pie scraper
to kind of chop the flour
into
the potato right which is is very
counter-intuitive
for
someone who has not made
gnocchi before so first what types of
potatoes
are the ideal potatoes to use and why
i like a classic idaho potato because
there's a high starch content and and
and you can like
you can cook the water out of them and
then
um
you know there's less moisture so then
you end up with like a dough that has
less flour and then ultimately a dough
that ends up being lighter on the palate
and should they be you like older
potatoes
yeah so i i often point to like fresh
peas i don't know if you've ever gotten
fresh peas that are in a pod but like
the thing about peas is you want to pick
them
and you want to keep ice on them so that
they keep their sugar
because that's a sweet pea
but when a pea loses its sugar the pea
goes to starch
and
that process happens with a lot of
vegetables and with an idaho potato you
don't want a fresh potato because it's
holding on to the sugar and it's the
starch that's going to help you
create a lighter dough so we used to
literally buy cases of potatoes and put
them in the cellar and let them i mean
we kind of aged the potatoes if you will
because we found that a potato
that's kind of aged that almost is
starting to sprout
ends up being
less water and less sugar and more
starch and that always lent itself to a
better gnocchi
and just you know i know you always
reference things in the show notes but
like
uh i was on the dave chang show
and and we talked you know we talked
about gnocchi quite a bit on that show
because he was at kraft when i was like
doing all of these things and we kind of
like
two old two old dogs talking about
kitchen stories but we went on and on
about the gnocchi on that podcast if
anybody wants to hear more about the
origins
and uh and you came to this
it sounds like largely through
through trial and error and yeah and
part of what impressed me right is the
sort of the detail in the simplicity if
that makes any sense so for instance if
you're if you're trying to
in the process of
cutting the potatoes evaporate as much
moisture as possible
cutting them lengthwise in a particular
way so that you have the maximum amount
of surface area exposed yeah right where
the
inclination for anyone who hasn't spent
a lot of time in the kitchen would be
like all right let me just take the
potato cut it
kind of right down the middle the way
you would think of cutting a tomato down
the middle
where you just have the kind of ends of
the cigars so to speak yeah exposed to
error but that's not going to actually
accomplish the job so even though
technically
both are easy right you're making one
cut like the direction matters a lot to
the outcome yeah so i just i love the
the simplicity but the thought behind
the simplicity right
uh there's there's a lot that goes into
it
when my girlfriend and i were in new
york city before we move on to other
questions because i mentioned in
somewhat cryptic
phrasing the the affair of the oven that
was not turned on i wanted to make it
sound like a sherlock holmes novel or
something
uh
i got to see
what like a a delivery of bad news
slash discipline looks like without
yelling and screaming which i thought
was very fascinating and
i wanna i'm just gonna kind of bookend
this story and then i'll let you tell it
okay so the the only part that i heard
that i then asked you about was you said
pretty calmly you said i heard you say
around the corner too a bunch of staff
you're like this isn't going to be fun
for anyone
[Laughter]
so
uh
so we met up i want to say the plan
it was either 10 or 11 a.m
and why don't you
tell the story of kind of what the what
the plan
was and then what happened yeah so you
know
[Laughter]
first i gotta say like i was i was
really thrilled when you reached out to
me and were like
hey do you know how to cook do you know
how to make gnocchi
and and would you do this i was like
that you know i i love teaching and and
to get a ping from you and ask that
question i was like i was overjoyed and
fully invested in this notion of like
teaching your girlfriend and your
girlfriend's mom how to make gnocchi
like it made my day to get that that
text
so
you know it took us a while to schedule
it and plan it but it's like oh you're
going to be in new york this weekend so
i had it all planned out and i thought
really hard about it and you you know if
you remember we had a lot of back and
forth leading up to it because we were
doing this via zoom and her mom was
going to be far away so she needed to
know what equipment to have yeah so it
was like you know you need a potato
ricer and you need a bench scraper and
so we did a lot of pre you know as i was
alluding to
earlier it's like it's all in the
misenplace right yeah so we did a fair
amount of work around
what's required
you guys showed up
and i had everything laid out and we had
our little food mill to pass the
potatoes
and like i had you know
it was like a little mini cooking class
on a saturday morning
i had aprons and towels and here's some
tea and it was like it was so fun and i
was so excited and uh it was plotted out
because we opened where we opened for
brunch at hearth so
the kitchen is a functioning kitchen so
we we only had a certain window to do
this like our lesson
and and furthermore
everything we were doing was happening
in parallel in
or wherever
yeah yeah yeah exactly so it's like
i don't want to say it was pressure but
this idea of like somebody else is going
to do what we're doing too kind of added
on to the
the kind of
need for
that we had to run in parallel
so but that's all cool and like the the
potatoes take an hour and 10 minutes to
cook in the oven that i have in my
basement because we do it every day
so i knew how long and
and so you showed up on time
and
i had put the potatoes in
uh because you know you had the time
that that's the only thing you have to
time is the cooking of the potato the
forming of the dough and the rolling and
then the cooking of the gnocchi
that's pretty easy and pretty fast but
like the big thing is the hour and ten
minutes so it was great you showed up
and we had our niceties and we had some
coffee and our hugs and all that stuff
and then it was like okay here's your
apron and i gave you a little we got we
got all the tech figured out and
everybody's on and it's go time
and i go downstairs
and i open the oven and the oven was not
on
and the [ __ ] the potatoes were rock
hard and and
and the oven was cold
and i swear i i i had a i had a mental
breakdown
because i i didn't quite register and
fathom the fact that that was an hour
and ten minutes lost and we have to
start over
and yeah there was a lot of moving parts
because
the mom now that's all messed up i don't
know what your day is like and our
brunch service starts
so yeah that was where the the this is
not going to be fun for anybody because
now i'm going to be teaching i wasn't
going to not teach you how to make
gnocchi so now i'm going to be like
taking up a big part of the pass uh
during brunch so
those that were responsible for brunch
had to basically work in a corner of a
kitchen and that's what i meant by like
this will not be fun
and yet it all came together it did and
it was fun
it was fun and you are an incredible
teacher and the gnocchi were spectacular
and
if i remember correctly
uh
sage
and butter
yeah and parmesan
parmesan yeah reggiano parmesan and salt
and pepper and that's it
oh
so good yeah so so good and we went to
italy my girlfriend and i for the first
time yeah umbria right
yeah that's right we went all over we
were in rome then went to umbria then
went to
through a couple of smaller places like
gubio i wanted to go to gubio because
there's a story of saint francis of
assisi brokering a truce with this huge
wolf oh wow story i'm fascinated by
and
supposedly
it was thought a myth
because how could it not be and then
there was a huge wolf skeleton
discovered right next to a church
at some point in history not within the
last hundred years and that was put
within the church there's this whole
story how cool and i found the whole
thing really interesting and it turned
out that
that uh gubio was going to be on the way
to our next spot and so we stopped
relatively so and then we went to
pompeii and then drove down and spent
time on the coast and went to a few
spots there and we had gnocchi a few
times and they were good they were
really really good they were not as good
as the ones that we made
in your kitchen in my opinion
and i gotta say man that is saying a lot
because as a friend of mine put it who's
italian he said you know in italy's he's
like
it's all going to be good like you just
have to find the excellent restaurants
like it's going to be really hard to
find a terrible restaurant
your job is just to find the excellent
spots and we we did find some excellent
spots and uh took a cooking class with
his grandma who was hilarious
and uh it was it was all outstanding but
but those gnocchi that we made in that
kitchen that day despite the
circumstances
were just were just incredible
you